in common with
the rest of the world covert was
profoundly disruptive to this show
we were in mexico city filming episode
5 when things got really bad and we had
no idea if it was going to be possible
to film the rest of the show one of our
principal characters is a teenage boy
and i was terrified
that by the time we got to remount in
2022 charlie would be six foot five with
a with a lumberjack beard
we're very lucky that we figured out a
clever way to come back to
shooting in a bubble in the safest way
possible we picked up
in guadalajara five months later this
isn't how it's supposed to be
i know but it is what it is i'd always
wanted to have
a story where two characters have to
cross the city on foot against time i
just want to write a thrilling chase
but with the kids i want to do something
a bit different mexico city is the most
fantastic city and it's that kind of
what do you get to do
when you're a teenager in a city like
that and your parents are gone
i've never been to mexico before it was
a culture shock at first
i've been trying to learn spanish which
has been kind of hard but it's been fun
do you like chocolate gabriel is he's
just hilarious because he
he really does have that energy of a 14
year old boy he is
energy to expend he's constantly you
know picking at things and obviously the
way
charlie he's written is he doesn't want
to see
flaws in his father dina by contrast
sees nothing but flaws
she does not want to be like ali dina's
tragedy is that she is ali i think she
yearns
for that normal life so she can just get
a sense of what it's like outside of
her dad charlie you don't want that
bourgeois hipster dilettantes come on
logan and i have a great banter that we
start at the beginning we have a really
close bond so i think
it's nice to have someone hang out with
on and off set and that really
comes across as like a sibling dynamic
on screen
this is fun i wanted to write a story
for a young american man
where we see a boy on the cusp of manna
charlie has very skewed ideas about what
it is to be a man
and i'm very interested in that fearful
desire to be able to prove one's
masculinity through violence
we see a crucial moment in the real
beginning
of charlie's journey the kids got a gun
[Music]
you